I honestly really never considered that
it would happen to me we're targeting
payday lenders and ammunition
manufacturers you're going after little
guys all over America government
regulators are essentially telling banks
that they need to be morality police our
businesses were started with our own
retirement and college fund dollars that
we had saved for our family Ellison who
asked that we only use her first name in
this story started this payday lending
and check cashing business with her
husband in 2010 it's located in Orange
County California a lot of my customers
take payday loans because they have
difficulty making a paycheck to paycheck
and it helps to pay the phone bill or
pay the rent allison runs a tight ship
and she successfully navigated the
complex permitting procedures and
regulations that govern this
controversial industry we had never had
any compliance issues we had never had
any slip of the hands or we did
something wrong we were always in full
compliance and then one day she got a
letter in the mail from the bank that
changed her life they were going to shut
my bank accounts down due to their
high-risk nature in 30 days I cannot do
business if I don't have a bank account
I can't do money transferring money
orders I can't deposit a check for any
business how do you do business without
a business checking account so Allison
tried to open an account in another Bank
but her application was denied so she
tried again and the same thing happened
so she closed her first store and her
second location is scheduled to go out
of business in a matter of weeks why was
she being cut off from the financial
system the banks wouldn't give her any
answers and wouldn't respond to any of
our questions either I had heard about
operation chop point through a couple of
contexts I have in this industry I
honestly really never considered that it
would happen to me operation choke point
is a government program that sought to
intimidate banks into closing the
accounts of a number of what they
consider to be high-risk industries
operation choke point was a program
created by the Obama administration's
financial fraud Enforcement Task Force
the government says it's over now but
business owners across the country
claimed that's not true it's a task
force that most Americans probably have
never heard of but it has more control
over the choices and decisions that
Americans make than almost any other
agency in the government brian wises the
president of the u.s. consumer coalition
a consumer advocacy group chokepoint was
supposed to be focused on mass market
consumer fraud when the program started
in 2013 but it quickly morphed into
something much bigger a way for federal
regulators to strong-arm banks into
punishing any type of business that
didn't meet their approval by putting
them on their list of high-risk
merchants government regulators are
essentially telling banks that they need
to be morality police that these banks
have to make moral decisions on who they
can and cannot do business with and they
have to make moral decisions on what
consumers should have access to and what
kind of businesses were on this list the
usual suspects were there debt
consolidation scams and online gambling
but also completely legitimate and legal
businesses like firearms sales coin
dealers tobacco sales and more in the
same way that we say that racial
profiling is bad you're saying that
without any due process these industries
and the merchants within these
industries are guilty of some kind of
wrongdoing simply because they offer a
legal product to America's consumers I
got started in the hukum business when I
was 18
Brennan Appel is the owner of Global
hookah a tobacco accessory seller like
Allison he also received an unwelcome
letter from his bank informing him that
his account would be shut down in 30
days I was in shock I didn't understand
I thought it was a mistake because I had
been with Bank of America since 2002
banks can terminate a customer's account
at any time and they have no legal
obligation to provide a reason so it can
be difficult sometimes to connect the
dots back to a federal policy like
Operation choke point but Appel got
confirmation after recording a phone
call with a payment processor who shut
down a large transaction he was trying
to complete with the customer
the nature of what we have what we do in
payment processing at least with our
processing bank has become so more
regimented and strict and focused on
compliance and certainly certain efforts
in Washington and I have you heard of a
little thing you know called choke point
you know the CFPB pretty much flat out
told me operation choke point is the
reason why my ACH account was closed
even though we had processing since 2005
and we had a clean record and had done
good about a business once enough
businesses from many different
industries began complaining about being
totally cut off from the financial
system the Congressional Committee on
Oversight and Reform questioned the DOJ
and FDIC about their conduct during a
hearing what gives you the right or
anybody that works for you the right to
tell businesses where the owners have
sacrificed their saving their hard works
grown their businesses hire their family
members and others what gives you the
right to try to shut them down sir we
don't have that right or authority
congressman oh you don't but you did it
didn't you that's something we've now
Anna story but you did it didn't you sir
I'm trying to during those committee
hearings FDIC officials as well as
Department of Justice officials have
denied their involvement in operation
choke point despite the fact that these
committees have emails that specifically
tie individuals at these agencies to
this program these are the official
documents of the FDIC going out to banks
and IV email chains showing that you're
targeting payday lenders and ammunition
manufacturers you're abusing your power
you're going after little guys all over
America
we have tried consistently
going back to when we received the
letter from the members of Congress to
respond to the concerns that have been
raised since then they have admitted to
the program existing and they have said
that they no longer are taking part in
the program that's actually true we
believe that the program has moved from
the Department of Justice and the FDIC
over to the CFPB remember this part of a
Pels phone call in the I have you heard
of a little thing you know called choke
point you know in the CFPB
I'm Richard Cordray the new director of
the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
and the Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau is the brainchild of progressive
Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
part of the architecture that I hope
we're going to build into this agency
it's not just transparency it's a real
engagement with American families this
agency belongs to the people
the CFPB is the only agency in the
federal government which operates
completely outside of any accountability
to Congress it operates under the
direction of a single unelected
political appointee and it can
essentially spend as much money as it
wants because it's under the guidance of
the Federal Reserve officials from the
CFPB refused to our request to appear in
this video but replied by email the
CFPB's concern is ensuring compliance
with federal consumer financial law they
also claim to have no records of any
involvement in cutting off global
hookahs bank account while government
agencies claim choke point is over what
we do know is that legally operating
business owners in various industries
across America are still receiving
letters of closure from their banks it
hasn't stopped the government is
doubling down on this program and will
continue to double down until the
administration changes I will be going
out of business very shortly and lost
most of my customers I believe that it
is still happening I know of other
people in the industry who have told me
as recently as two weeks ago that their
accounts are getting shut down a lot of
times with government they'll push you
to the limit but you know you have to be
old to stand up so hopefully more
people can come forward and make this
much more well-known